الاخبار من الجزيره السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله في ختامه لقاءات عقدها في القدس ورام
الله شدد وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه على ان
على طرفين الاسرائيلي والفلسطيني اجراءات
لخفض العنف ومنع مزيد من التصعيد وجدد
موقفها لدرجه الامريكيه المتماسكه بحل
الدولتين كما ادعى الى الحفاظ على الوضع
القانوني والتاريخي للاراضي المقدسه
من جانبه حمل الرئيس الفلسطيني محمود عباس
الحكومه الاسرائيليه كاملا المسؤوليه عن
التصعيد والتوتر التي تشهده الاراضي
الفلسطينيه وشدد على ان الفلسطينيين لا
يقبلون استمرار الاحتلال للابد
مددت السلطات هو التونسيه حاله الطوارئ في
البلاد الى نهايه العام الجاري وفاه ما
جاء في مرسوم صدر في الجريده الرسميه وتعد
هذه المره الاولى التي تمدد فيها الطوارئ
لعام كامل
دعا رئيس التونسي وقيس سعيد القوات هي
المسلحه والامنيه والقضاه للتصدي متامرين
على الدوله
بينما اتهم رئيس جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه احمد
نجيب بشاب الرئيس سعيد بالتوظيف القضايا
العسكريه للانتقام من خصومه واصدار احكام
كلها تتعلق بتدوينات او تصريحات اعلاميه
نقلت رويترز عن الولايات المتحده تستعد
لتقديم حزمه المساعدات امنيه جديده
لاوكرانيا بقيمه مليارين والمئتين مليون
دولار واضافتنا المساعده العسكريه الجديده
تتضمن صواريخ طويله المدى للمره الاولى
وصف الكريم لينا بولندا ودول البلطيق
بالعدوانيه واقلانه من المخزيه من الدول
الاوروبيه الكبرى لا تضع حدا لها واضاف ان
دول البلطيق وبولندا على استعداد لفعل كل
ما يثير المزيد من المواجهه مع روسيا دون
التفكير في العواقب قال وزير الخارجيه
الاوكراني بين البدء المبكره في المفاوضات
نحو عضويه اوكرانيا في الاتحاد الاوروبي
سيكون الموضوع الرئيسي في القمه الاوروبيه
الاوكرانيه يوم الجمعه المقبل مضيفنا
النبي
من السوق الاوروبيه الداخليه
قالت وزاره الداخليه الفرنسيه ان عدد
المشاركين في التظاهرات الاحتجاجيه ضد
تعديل النظام التقاعد فاقا مليون وربعا
مليون متظاهره رفقت الاحتجاجات مع موجه
اضرابات عن العمل شملت عددا من القطاعات
الحيويه بينها التعليم والمواصلات العامه
والطاقه والمستشفيات
اشكركم على متابعه
اوقاتكم بكل خير
[موسيقى]